I do that
second left
what Martin's going to do Willie pull up
and shoot two three did that right
before the hand or he could drive on
[Applause]
Oh watch it again as James Harden caused
Ricky Rubio to lose some clothing right
here and he fell into a sinkhole how in
agreeance mix raised on those ankles wow
that was just dirty which route 70 goes
after the second
at last shot by heart wasn't too
this one steps back for Bernie he was
just trying to get his reign for the
t-wolves yeah James puts up a long free
to beat the buzzer
play off the beautiful feed final
seconds of the first Terry to harden
pardon at the buzzer
for the second clearly gets it off in
time
as harden it's his first three-pointer
it was well defended he was fouled
too many better athletes and Jonathan
Simmons who went to smiley high school
here in Houston played for the U of A 20
Mara and James whether Frey
on the run this the clock goes to zero
as the ball settles through the chords
the clock they go into hard-working on
game top of the key
raises up Billy
[Applause]
Arnon Chandler steps back and hits the
three and just as the shot clock expires
tough to score on these days Li's in a
long three ball at it my heart it's
gonna count tough the fall from 30-plus
Tony Allen's got his arm out there James
gets just every single game as soon as
that arms is out James what goes up
right through it and banks it
for watches check out the beater to
chill across over lands tom has had to
pick his socks off the floor among other
things to open that trap door
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
play with the big guy now this is those
five feet behind a line one at 28
degrees
that's Baytown here a three or four
those already today deep threes Wells
exactly to the quarter is hard to beat
the buzzer
any day a reason in the first half the
beard and the third quarter this shot
from James heart which beats the buzzer
[Music]
when a ruddy breathin beat the shot
clock that was off the wrong foot
also the shot clock is running down
that's why he's got to shoot him
jumps off the left leg and shoots with
his left hand which is a little bit
awkward but he was able to drain that
swish
fire was
[Music]
[Applause]
thirty-two points six assists five
rebounds and tonight he is 6 of 12 the
seeds of the Taco Bell Skills Challenge
last night goes to live on social media
archiving with the photos of designing a
custom trophy for Chris tapas porzingis
[Music]
it will count a rare four-point
opportunity coming up here
for James Hart and then I'm getting
James on the arm as he's going up to
shoot and he's able to bank it home
that's money right there Craig thank you
Roberson cuts and misses a layup
[Applause]
pardon met by the current final seconds
of the first there's hot yes with three
tenths of a second remaining in this
first quarter
April ahead hiding at the buzzer James
Harden from downtown
you play so choose pulls the trigger
fire J's hartney 8 for 8 from the field
first quarter points Pella draymond
Green on five to shoot pardon stop
spires three-pointer bats girls of step
clock expires Martin
hurry switches off Florida shooting
harden shaken bake steps back three
quarter
Mike D'Antoni says 30 minutes there's no
way in the world I'm gonna sit and watch
my best player shot clock at 7 seconds
hezonia and hardened heart steps back
fires
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
looking for some company wrench obliges
step to the side thrills the three plays
to go watch this left right back back Oh
what's it going through it that
especially is it big guy
Chris gets in back however shot clock
down to two seconds you got to take it
fighting pretty good at beating that
buzzer
I think it was certain to work I thought
it was going to be Oh he stared at
Wesley Johnson and then he gets to three
he put him on the deck and then he
hesitated
take a look mommy have this dad dal-gu
Johnson too much sauce
final seconds of the half
here's heart
James Hornet beats the buzzer 21 for the
beard and another look at it he too
hesitated but buried it there on
hardened comes down to baseline forced
into a tough shot Ramsey's Ole Miss but
you only have a second on the shot clock
hey we'll take that hey three is better
than two eighteen seconds left to play
rockets need a three
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
man to guard shot clock is down to two
with a serene blanket Ellen of three
years away so my the slow dance out here
James Harden choosing the music he
caught abundant Todd a little bump - it
seemed like undrafted in 2015 played
overseas for a couple of years it's been
an impressive rookie this year as harden
hits the foie
[Applause]
yes it was but again it's Hank James art
was actually looking more to get fine I
would expect that he would sit here in
the fourth quarter now the four seconds
down to three razzle-dazzle
James Harden with his night three of the
game when I won again with all the Depot
[Applause]
step into the corner did a shooting very
tough shot and very simpler than the
shot clock winding down second to get on
the shot clock it's been all hardens
basketball he's got to finish but he's
got it the holy 24 and he done that
really helped him
step back by Harden just before the shot
clock buzzer went off between a hard and
boring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a half a hundy forehead bet play
in this game tonight here's another
opportunity gets hit on the elbow as he
drains another step-back three that's
now 6 for 11 from the three-point line 4
on the shot clock
bad pass some heart finds its way Dennis
Barnes gonna actually put it up just
gets it off the time and of course hits
it James Harden from downtown that's
good defense that offense by James
Harden my first shooting 55% from the
field
they've hit 12 threes they have 21
assists let's be honest
[Music]
now double-team comes over and Martin
beats it anyway the penalty look at how
much space James needs to get off of
three-point shots
not very much he was deep in that corner
on that play both guys were determined
to get a play for their team
hardly
[Applause]
[Music]
step back
and that may be the game winner Dantzler
dancing again
[Music]
Artie thanks Dustin tries it again gas
voice by heartless
at 34 to 20 quarter and the Rockets
inbound
pardon trying to get three down to three
down two turrets a
James Harden of flamethrower incredible
shot have been fouled in the grill of
draymond Green a former Defensive Player
of the Year these chops
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
down man down and he fouled him so hard
and drains the three and gets an addled
look at Chris Paul easy ones around the
rim are going with a step-back three got
another one shaking his head
look at it Milwaukee's bench saying you
can't guard me now for the last seven in
a row for Houston how much you can do
against that
step backs just like the dream shake
James Harden
three points away he dances back cakes
and hits James Harden gets his 30 points
to extend the streak to 25 straight and
that's cappella Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah 33 footer I mean he's out there 40
feet
he's smarting over there on the opposite
side the floor the defense by Kyrie
James just watches I watch to the top of
the screen you gonna see him here he
comes he go and he still gets it up
Damion Lee comes in for the first time
curry and green return plays hard knocks
down his first three-pointer of the game
but how about the kind of separation
Mike he gets with that step back seven
seconds
on the shot clock
[Music]
oh look at this three right here at the
top of the three-point line is 23 feet 9
inches the windows church super-mo will
show you that he's at least 10 feet
behind that oh my goodness 165 game
classy 45% warriors of 25% rockets would
never let warriors of white by 14 lock
again down to 5 our step back grave
Martin tonight three of seven Thompson's
defense there
[Music]
[Applause]
in his career
dances with the basketball what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content